my channel is sponsored by scentbird
which means we will hear more from them
in a couple of minutes hello lovely
people i'm alana and welcome to this
weekly news thing that i've been doing
where i try to cover gaming news that i
feel positively about because there is
already enough negative gaming news
here on youtube the positive stuff
doesn't get enough views but i don't
care
so i'm covering it
uh the first story that i wanted to talk
about this week there are a couple of
things that i want to talk about but the
first one
is
something that i also want to talk about
with a little bit of urgency because i
am worried it's probably going to get a
cease and desist
which is the shadow of skyrim nemesis
and alternative death system mod
for skyrim essentially what this is
which is my words not theirs
wb don't sue them because i said this
because of course the nemesis system is
patented now
it's basically a mod that uh creates a
system like shadow of motor's nemesis
system and puts it into skyrim which is
super super cool i know they've been
working on this for a long time i
believe there were a bunch of community
updates as this whole thing was coming
together but i just think it's so
awesome and i know
when this stuff came out oh sorry the
nemesis system itself came out
there was this period of time where i
kept being like how has every other game
studio not done this why is nobody doing
this because it's so cool
and it turns out that that could have
been because the patent was pending um
so nobody wanted to touch it with a
10-foot pole which really sucks for
creativity obviously this mod though
hopefully they can skirt uh guidelines
so
we have about this mod and i'll leave a
link to this page below if you want to
check it out um it makes every enemy
that defeats you into a unique nemesis
provides continuous gameplay experience
without saving slash reloading creates
emergent stories of revenge so
the continuous gameplay experience
without saving flash reloading is a very
interesting point because if you were to
reload then you would lose the data
that's tied to which of the enemies that
killed you became your nemesis so
instead i believe it spawns you in the
world automatically you don't actually
reload a save um okay what shadow of
skyrim does it turns any enemy who
defeats you into a nemesis with a unique
name increased stats and a special buff
eg argonian vampire named breaks many
shields with shield breaker above
gives the player a situation or random
debuff upon defeat eg cannot use shields
allows your nemesis to take your gear
and use it eg breaks many shields maybe
clad in your chitten armor next time you
meet him if your armor is better than
his encourages exploration by respawning
the player to a new situation or random
location upon defeat again i think that
that's actually very cool especially the
situational ones which it elaborates on
here eg vampire layer because breaks
many shields it's vampire
uh gives the player a quest to track
down your nemesis dropped slash dropped
backpack with immersive directions
this is actually like super impressive
to me because um
what it does is when you die and you
know you get your nemesis who now has a
name and has a buff and you have a
debuff related to that nemesis it
actually adds the
quest to your quest log
uh the mod also motivates the player to
complete nemesis quest eg defeating
breaks many shields will remove the
cannot use shield's debuff so it
obviously is a priority
um and will grant you the shield breaker
buff and provides a continuous gameplay
experience without saving and reloading
you respawn after defeat instead of
dying and reloading intentionally
synergizes with other mods that add new
enemies locations abilities and perks
and
i read somewhere also that it very
specifically
makes sure that you won't have a nemesis
that is over 25
levels above you i believe it is uh so
that you would never get a nemesis that
you cannot possibly defeat or are very
very far away from defeating as that
would make the game kind of unplayable
it is time to talk about scentbird which
is a monthly subscription box that
delivers beautiful new fragrances to
your door every month i am a very big
fan
of smelling good and of other people
smelling good i will never stop talking
about how people in australia my home
country all wear perfume and cologne and
walk around smelling amazing like you'll
smell somebody and your head will turn
it doesn't happen as much in the u.s and
canada and i miss it so much scentbird
has got you covered even if you've never
worn perfume before i really want to
encourage it because this is such great
value but also great sense so this one
is called just bloom made in italy it's
very fresh it's kind of flowery
and also like how cool are these little
cases perfect for traveling now this one
is michelle germain paris it's called
sexual but it's like all fancy it's like
sexual
and i feel like this one um which i've
worn the most actually has like a really
formal kind of smell and then the third
one i got this month
here is floral street neon rose and
smells as you would expect
very very floral they're all very
different and distinct and it's cool
because you can either pick one that you
like from what they send you every month
or wear them for different occasions
which is what i've been doing and using
scentboard is actually a very fun kind
of experiment because it lets you figure
out what exactly your style is so yeah
scentbird lets you choose from new
designer fragrances every month starting
at 17
that is such good value you have no idea
every month you get to pick what you
want to receive so there aren't any
surprises it's not like a lucky dip type
thing you actually get to curate what
you want and try them all out and then
you get brands the likes of which i will
never own anything else from other than
these scentbird perfumes like gucci and
prada of course there are perfumes
colognes unisex options lots of options
and with each fragrance you get a 30 day
supply so you can pick which one you
like
and then if you really fall in love with
one you can just buy the whole bottle so
make sure you use my coupon code alana
p2 for 55 off your first month at
scentbird so yeah here we go by default
enemies 25 levels above the player will
not become your nemesis when they defeat
you this is meant to prevent you from
having nemesis that are too difficult to
defeat
uh
too difficult to beat rather this option
can be disabled and customized that's
super cool too um and obviously the
alternative death system is that you
don't reload or save so
followers can revive you in battle
followers have a limited time to defeat
your enemy and revive you as well that's
super cool
uh they also went on to say i plan to
continue adding more content to this mod
more nemesis titles and buffs player
debuffs reward rebuffs respawn
situations additional mechanics this is
just
i just think it's so cool again that was
a system that when it came out
i was so excited about it i thought was
so cool i still think is very cool and
was like why isn't it in more games
of course trust the modding community to
make it happen
so excited to see what they do with star
field i feel like that's going to pull
together those
30 000 planets or whatever they said
which is just too many
um yeah this is this is so so so so cool
yeah if you're still playing um skyrim
and you're interested you could maybe
check it out maybe a fanfic here
i think it is
anyway super cool i love that that this
was uh made so that is the first story
of the week is shadow of skyrim uh love
to see it the second story of the week
which
is also just
so cool it's it does kind of suck that
my third story is an exception to this
but that the first two stories are just
like kind of things that the community
has done and not actual gaming news
stories
thus is the state of the times so this
is from at new underscore cheats
underscore news on twitter who said
while doing some request work casually
found some new cheats and super punch
out for snes
all secret codes in this game uses two
button combinations two of them are
known sound test and japanese name input
but there are two more add the title
hold y plus r then press a or start
following screen will appear instead of
regular menus here you can select any
character to fight in free single match
see you in fighters from special circuit
are available here which okay this gets
cooler but the fact that this is only
being discovered now
this game came out in 94. it's older
than i am no it's a year younger than i
am i take it back and bought in 93.
i can't count even more in this free
match mode character info screen to hold
b plus y then press a or start from now
the cpu opponent can be controlled from
joypad2 so you can fight against a real
person and that's the meaty part of this
news which is why this is effectively a
hidden two-player mode
that nobody knew about
for 28 years
and somebody just kind of found it again
apparently doing some request what
casually found some new cheats in a 28
year old game
uh i love punch out i have a lot of love
for punch-out and um this is super
exciting and it's cool that you're
seeing people in their replies
this is obviously not a hug people in
their replies being like oh yeah i just
did it um this person said this is
really neat found a few nuances with it
mad clown has moves that will cause to
crash this person did not have issues
with mad clown crashing the game
how was the cheat discovered asking out
of interest see i've been doing this for
hundreds of games i believe he looks at
the disassembled code oh that's
interesting yeah just another like very
very cool thing that uh
this account does tend to post a lot of
cool easter eggs cool game cheats it's
actually really really fascinating i'm
surprised that they don't have more
followers it's a it's a very very
um
cool way to spend your time in my
opinion
okay to the third story so i want to say
first that i feel positively about this
not because of what i do
because of what they're doing but more
so because
this is a company actually doing
something instead of just saying
something and i think this is awesome
like even if you disagree with what
they're doing here for political reasons
um and how they phrased it which is
certainly very cards against humanity
very brash um that's it's true to their
brand for sure i just thought it was
really cool that they are actually
taking some kind of action rather than
just writing a tweet like most
corporations do it's so hollow so cards
against humanity is donating 100 of
profits from orders from the following
states alabama arizona arkansas florida
georgia idaho indiana kentucky louisiana
mississippi missouri north dakota ohio
oklahoma south carolina south dakota
tennessee texas utah west virginia
wisconsin and wyoming if you buy cards
against humanity from any of these
states they will donate 100 profits to
the national network of abortion funds
today we are releasing some new packs
but while the packs were being printed
the supreme court overturned roe v wade
and your state immediately turned itself
into a dystopian force worth hellscape
again i'm quoting them that's their
words so we're donating 100 of profits
from orders to your nightmare state to
the national network of abortion funds
plus a hundred thousand dollars right
now to help the people most [ __ ] over
by the republicans in your state
government we don't need your money we
also wanted to know what on earth the
people in your state were thinking so we
asked him a few questions you will
unfortunately believe what we found for
the love of god don't forget to vote um
so again this is very cards against
humanity and phrasing but putting your
money where your mouth is man they are
donating 100 profits and i'm just i
think i'm just finding it weird seeing
so many corporations tweet stuff
and then do absolutely nothing about it
cards against humanity
i don't think are like a perfect
organization nobody is but they have
done
some things that i think are
technically marketing
but that i see as being
quite selfless in a way that i wanted to
give an extra shout out to as this story
came up because i wish that
more game studios more companies in the
gaming space um of course they are a
card game but they're still that's still
part of gaming um would take their
approach
and at least in how genuine they are
with a lot of their marketing stuff so
there's one other thing that i really
wanted to share here that i thought was
awesome so the second one here this is
from 2017. if you haven't heard this
story
i also just thought this is really cool
they really detail the whole thing this
is a few weeks ago we exhibited at
emerald city comic con typically when we
attend conventions we try to create some
spectacle that captures people attention
and sells games like the time we bought
a marching band to pax australia shout
out to pax australia
see a sign here says nobody is watching
this booth take what you want and pay a
fair price which is exactly what they
did
at eccc we set up a pay what you want
booth and encourage people to give us
any amount of money in exchange for our
games we put games on the table set up
some signs stood off to the side and
waited to see what would happen
we bought 2 000 games before the
convention began we took bets on what
would happen tom thought we'd sell out
in a few hours alex thought we'd run out
on the second day of the con trenton
thought that we would not run out of
games because we are no longer cool or
relevant judd got a fever and didn't
know what was happening we were all
wrong the doors opened and attendees
swarmed the booth within five minutes
attendees realized they could just take
games and walk away a small group
grabbed armfuls of the free games and
left but most people that does suck but
most people paid something within an
hour the booth looked like this so one
hour
until it was completely gone we ran
under games in 51 minutes and made eight
thousand dollars and forty sorry eight
thousand and forty two dollars or 18.7
percent of the game's retail value in
other words we lost 685
per
minute and the booth cost 43 000
that's nuts um though i do want to know
if you weren't already a web that a lot
of companies do consider conventions to
be a
kind of a financial sink because of
things like shipping cost or freight or
whatever just to get all of the product
actually to the show floor and then set
up the booth so generally it is more
about marketing which is obviously what
they use this opportunity for or about
community engagement and a lot less
about making money uh tani's put lots of
other stuff in the payment box too
that's actually really cool i like that
the free pizza some things you put in
our po box five canadian dollars 10
euros 80 philippine pesos one chinese
yuan one cubone pokemon card xy
breakthrough
one magic the gathering eternal masters
booster pack rapper cool handwritten any
pizza free and twisted flicks plus kpc
coupon from papa murphy's and kirkland
wa that's actually awesome one one
dollar bill folded into a bow tie
one feeltheburn.org one dollar bill and
two halves of a one dollar bill
wow you stole a lot of games this is why
we can't have nice things so they
updated it once we sold out we figured
we had to figure out what to do with our
boot space on saturday we gave space to
artists who weren't able to get a table
at the con people showed up to exhibit
cosplay horns board games recycled
journals and comic art that is very cool
on the last day of the con we set up a
station for mailing letters to
representatives write a letter to the
government we provided pens paper
postage envelopes writing tips and the
address of every us senator and i guess
the idea was that you could write
whatever you wanted and they would be
mailed um over 200 letters were written
by conatoni's including the most badass
imperative imperator imperator imperator
furiosa cosplay we've ever seen
that's very cool again this is marketing
but there's bad marketing in the games
industry and there's this again i will
talk about that for spoken uh trailer
that blew up on twitter controversially
in my next q a because enough people
have asked me about it that i was like
this has to be in the q a there's so
many youtube comments people asking me
about it um but i just think you know
they they have done some very genuine
seeming marketing it's of course still
marketing it is still uh done to to get
people like me to talk about it
but they have just a history of doing
the stuff and again i don't believe they
have like a fully tidy history i think
the cards against humanity has done some
questionable things as an organization i
just don't know what those are i just
want to point that out because i'm not
trying to say like they're an incredible
company it's just i think that other
companies in the industry have things to
learn in terms of marketing and in terms
of like how to actually appeal to people
uh where it seems like such a struggle
in some cases if there's anything that
i've learned in my time working in
tripoli game development this is not to
speak in my own studio just now that i'm
in game dev rather than in game
journalism world the people that i've
always known in game never a lot more
honest with me than they used to be
because they're not hiding anything the
developers in the marketing teams do not
get on that relationship is like
if you felt negatively about something
to do with video game marketing my
perspective from friends who work in the
industry would be that the studios felt
negative long before you did
and then just seethed when the community
reaction was negative as well and the
devs were like we [ __ ] told you
marketing and the marketing team goes
and nobody gets upset with them just
putting that context out there so those
are my three stories this week it was
actually kind of like a light week on
games news and i suspect that that is
because gamescom is coming up i have
some cool stuff planned for gamescom i
have some uh games that i've already got
exclusive hands-on locked in for that i
will be able to post as soon as the
embargoes are up it might do some
interviews and definitely do some
reactions to some trailers so stay tuned
for that that is the week of my birthday
i think it actually starts on my
birthday august 24th um so that's
probably why there's not a lot of news
right now is that all the news is
logically just waiting for gamescom it
happens but thank you all for watching
this week's good news or news that i
feel positively about as i guess i
should title it more realistically i
hope you feel positive too my friends
and thank you again to scentbird for
sponsoring the video link is in the
description if you want to check them
out i use it i smell good it's great
i'll see you guys next time bye